january 2014.
i think if we go through to
may 2014 we get to witn 3499014
please
um
this is uh 30th of may 2014. this is now
addressed only to the
the junior minister although it's said
to be copied to all other ministers um
and to special advisors
um and it's an update um we see that
from the title and paragraph one to
provide you as requested with an update
on the work on the possible
restructuring and retargeting of the
contaminated blood expression payment
schemes into a single simplified scheme
for all infected by hov and or hepatitis
c and through treatment with nhs supply
blood or blood products and i i don't um
propose to go through the detail of it
but it refers to having received advice
about how the existing schemes could be
dismantled and
how potentially a new structure
could be created
um now it's it's in the middle of 2014
as i understand it that
the prime minister
indicated
um that there could be an additional 25
million pounds
made available as a one-off sum and if
we just look at a document relating to
that and then i want to ask you a bit
more about that
witn
349015
um this is an email dated the 3rd of
june 2014
um and it's from i think will jones is
your private office
um and then it
says um
the pm has responded and we have a bit
of clarity on the direction of travel
the pm would like an additional 25
million pounds added as a one-off sum
from dh d8 should set out how we think
the money should be used at the pm
agreed to a review and streamlining the
system of financial support
the pm agreed that the secretary of
state should express regret to the
individuals who've become infected this
include publishing with dh documents
relating to the infections early and
then there's a sentence that's
incomplete i don't know why um
what um what what's your recollection of
of
how
the the decision was reached in relation
to this 25 million pounds it was not
formally announced until the following
year but just in terms of the
decision-making in the middle of 2014.
so i'm not sure quite how we got to that
point i think it's entirely possible
that
it was a suggestion from me that we find
25 million pounds to give you an idea of
context and this might surprise um
some people but in the sort of
115
odd billion pounds budget
i had an informal understanding from the
with the
department of health finance team
that i would have a discretionary 50
million pounds a year that i could use
for
emergencies or things that came up
during the year that was 50 million
pounds that was effectively an unfunded
pressure to use their language but
um we agreed that in the current
financial context there was a need
sometimes for a secretary of state to be
able to
spend a bit of money to solve a problem
and so
as i say i suspect what happened is that
there were discussions
um with number 10 probably not directly
with the prime minister but with the
prime minister's health advisor
um
about what are you willing to do about
the
[Music]
concerns that campaign groups have about
the way the ahos are functioning
we would have explained that to
address their concerns
was ultimately going to be a
multi-billion pound issue which the
treasury said they weren't willing to
fund
we would have said as the department of
health
you know the most we can afford
as an interim measure is 25 million
pounds which had been half that the
total allocation that i
would have had and that we were willing
to to do that as a as a temporary
measure and then um
[Music]
there would have been a discussion i
suspect again not with the prime
minister but with the prime minister's
health advisor
um and on the basis of that will jones
would have
written this note
and
um i think you you tell us or you
describe in your statement it is a as a
contingency pot this this 50 million
pounds
um that that that you held
and
is it fair to say that
um the 25 million pounds was
in a sense an arbitrary figure it
recognized money that you you could lay
your hands on
rather than being a figure that was
um
identified as a solution to the to the
problem that is absolutely correct i
mean we were scrabbling around for money
and um
you know we um i think at this time we
were waiting for the penrose report to
come out
um
i think we had an expectation as i think
campaigners did that it would be much
more substantive
than it actually ended up being
and so we thought we were likely to have
gonna have to
um properly address the issue then and
that was going to be my moment when i
would go to the treasury and say we
really do need to find some extra money
for this
so i was thinking what can we do to get
us to the point where penrose is
published
given that
people need extra support now so i think
i would have said okay well i will
but
just to be absolutely clear um this was
not an official
uh pot of money um it was not written
down anywhere it was an informal
understanding between me and
my
finance director the department of
health that there was occasionally gonna
be need for things like this
um and
that was uh so yes i think we thought
well okay this is a serious issue we'll
allocate half of our
contingency plot to this
and we don't need to go to it but
there's a there's a submission dated the
8th of july 2014 i'm going to just read
the reference into the into the
transcript of the record it's witn
3499016
and it provides um advice on
um options for the spending of that 25
million pounds
um if if we come forward then a little
to october 2014 again just to follow it
through chronologically
lawrence could we have witn 3499017
um this is as we see from the bottom of
the page dated the 29th of october 2014.
um and
we can see from the heading business
case for dh policy proposal
reform of the system of ex gracia
financial assistance for people infected
pre-91 with hiv and hepatitis c
and so on
and then the first paragraph explains
that the department proposes to consult
on on reforming the system uh four lines
in it describes the current system as
complex um and
with a number of shortcomings
and then the last sentence of that
paragraph is dh therefore proposes to
reform the system
so that it's more
rational fair and flexible
um
and then paragraph two says in order to
achieve this some redistribution of
resources would be required and
consequently this proposal will be
contentious for those who see a
reduction in or end to the payments they
receive
under the current system so
what was being looked at is is this
right at this point in time
as a as a possible route
subject to consultation was reorganizing
again the expectation was within the
existing
budget envelope
um
the way in which the
system was both structured and the
nature of the payments that were made
which might result in some who who were
currently receiving payments
no longer receiving those payments
well this is why it was a nonsense way
forward because you know in a context of
people having suffered an injustice
where
everyone was not getting the sums of
money that they
needed or should have been entitled to
it was
it was a dead end to think that one way
we could address this issue was by
reorganizing
the schemes that existed if that meant
that we were going to be cutting
payments to
some people who
given that you know no one was getting
what they deserved
um and i i don't need to go through the
detail of it but um again for the
benefit of those listening and paragraph
nine on the next page identified that
this would be a contentious policy
change um with a significant risk of
legal challenge attached to it
particularly from those who might
receive less under the new system so we
didn't actually pursue that so i think
it was understood that even though that
was advice it wasn't good advice
now there was a draft
consultation document however building
on this that was produced i'm not going
to go to it because it wasn't the
consultation document that was
ultimately issued but again for the
benefit of anyone um wanting to follow
the detailed chronology um
the draft consultation document is dated
november 2014 and is witn 3499018
and that was sent to
um
jane ellison
um in november 2014
and and again the reference for that is
witn 3499019
um
can i at this point pick up the
narrative in your statement um mr hunt
so if we could have on the screen
lawrence witn349901
and go to
page 43
so we can see in paragraph 33.17
of your statement
and you refer to um
the draft consultation document and the
submission being sent to jane ellison
that's the document i've just referred
to
and then you say the hope was that the
12-week consultation process could be
completed before the general election of
the 7th of may 2015.
in the event the consultation process
was delayed possibly out of a desire to
wait for the penrose inquiry report
which was expected to comment on issues
of financial support
as well as the need to study the work
that had been published by the appg
on the 14th of january 2015.
so it sounds from that as though the
reason this didn't go ahead was not
because of a departmental
acknowledgement that it was nonsense but
because
other things were going on in the
background that might affect
the position is that right
um i'm not quite sure when the 25
million pounds was
agreed
um but if if this was after the 25
million pounds i think this might have
been after the 25 million pounds was
agreed what i was saying was nonsense
was the idea that you could reorganize
the scheme without putting any extra
money into it because then although you
might make it
more logical you would have people
losing out and that would be very unfair
so that was what i was referring to as
nonsense
and and in terms of about 25 million my
understanding is
from your statement and the documents is
that it was agreed
between
you and the prime minister or at
official level whatever it might be in
the middle of 2014
but it was not announced until march
2015 and we'll come on to the
announcement
um
so
that that takes us to the end of 2014
at the beginning of 2015 we have as
alluded to in your statement the
publication by the appg of um of its
report
um if we just briefly go to that
uh it's rlit 5031
um and we see that um the the
description of the report and the date
january 2015. now i'm not going to ask
you about the detail of it mr hunt the
inquiries looked at this report with uh
with other witnesses in earlier hearings
but as i understand it from your
statement you don't expect that you
would have read this report you would
expect that that was a matter being
dealt with by jane ellison
correct although i may well have read
summaries of it in the media um and i'm
sure i was aware of it
um
so we then get to
march 2015 25th of march was the
publication of the penrose report
um
you've
alluded already to that the fact that
the department
um
might be putting it too strongly because
they had an expectation that the report
might be
more far-reaching in its recommendations
that than it was
um
do you recall what the your response was
or the department's reaction was when
the penrose report was finally produced
i think we thought it was a bit of a
damp squib
um but
i don't think we
thought that that
was necessarily a good thing if if the
penrose report had come up with some
specific
recommendations for scotland
um
that would have meant that i could have
gone to the treasury and
and said this is what we should do in
england and we need you to give us the
extra resources to do it
and it would have been a lever that
would have allowed me to do that and
quite possibly i would have had the
support of number 10 in that situation
so
um
i think
from a departmental point of view um
as someone who was aware
that there was an issue here that needed
to be resolved it meant that i didn't
have that
that lever that i was hoping might have
been there
um
we can see from your statement so if we
put the statement back on screen please
lawrence witn
3499001 and the same page again page 43.
we
will see the prime minister's
announcement
um in response to or on the same day as
the publication so bottom of the page
um
it is on the same day the prime minister
offered an apology for what had happened
and announced the additional 25 million
pounds of funds and then that you've set
out the text of the prime minister's
announcement my honourable friend is
absolutely right to raise this with the
penrose report being published today i
can do all of the three things he asks
for i know that many members on all
sides of this house have raised the
question of infected blood and i've
spoken about how constituents have been
to my surgeries
while it would be for the next
government to take account of these
findings it is right that we use this
moment to recognize the pain and the
suffering experienced by people as a
result of this tragedy
it is difficult to imagine the feelings
of unfairness that people must feel
being infected with something like
hepatitis c or hiv as a result of a
totally unrelated treatment within the
nhs
to each and every one of those people i
would like to say sorry on behalf of the
government for something that should not
have happened
no amount of money can ever fully make
up for what did happen but it is vital
that we move as soon as possible to
improve the way that payments are made
to those infected by this blood
i can confirm today that the government
will be will provide up to 25 million
pounds in 2015-16 to support any
transitional arrangements to a better
payment system
i commit that if i'm prime minister in
may we will respond to the findings of
this report as a matter of priority
and just to understand the significance
of the dates
that's the 25th of march parliament was
dissolved on the 30th of march
and a general election held on the 7th
of may 2015. correct
and so is it right to understand in
accordance with the
general conventions
that in that intervening period you
would not expect to be making
significant policy announcements until
the election had taken place
correct and also the right place for
those policing announcements to be made
would be parliament and parliament was
dissolved for the general election
um
can we just look at the written
ministerial statement that you um
issued
on the day of the penrose inquiry report
was
published
so that's at macf
5022 underscore 045
we can see it's written statement made
by
you 25th of march 2015.
um
in the last sentence of the first
paragraph um you
echo what the prime minister had said i
would like to say on behalf of this
government how sorry we are for what's
happened and express my sympathy for the
pain and grief suffered by many infected
people in their families
and then in the next paragraph you refer
to
the support schemes and and and you say
in the second sentence the system is
involved in an ad hoc and incremental
manner now comprising five infection
focus schemes that operate according to
their own individual criteria
uh you refer to there haven't been
improvements and then you say that
despite these improvements they've been
continued criticisms of the system
and then there's a reference to the
amongst other things the appg report
um
and then
if we pick it up
in the fourth paragraph
beginning i thank both the on member and
you say in the second sentence it's with
frustration and sincere regret that our
considerations on the design of a future
system have been subject to postponement
while we awaited publication of lord
penrose's final report of his inquiry in
scotland
we had hoped to consult during this
parliament on reforming the ex-croatia
financial assistance schemes considering
amongst other options a system based on
some form of individual assessment
however i felt it was important to
consider fully lord penrose's report
before any such consultation given its
publication today we clearly are not in
a position to launch a consultation on
one of the last sitting days of this
parliament
um and then in the next paragraph second
sentence you say whilst it will be for
the next government to consider all of
lord penrose's findings
i would hope and fully expect proposals
for improving the current complex
payment system to be brought forward
with other uk health departments
and then there is a reference to again
to the 25 million pounds
so
we
we we know obviously um
that
uh the government was reelected
you remained
secretary of state um for health so i
want to pick matters up next in june
post post-election to june 2015.
um but before we look at any further
documents
the the one recommendation that had been
made by the penrose inquiry report was a
recommendation in relation to
offering testing for hepatitis c
to those who'd had
transfusion
was any work undertaken by the
department of health
to your knowledge to consider the
applicability of that recommendation to
england
i don't know um
my understanding from the documents i've
read
uh preparing for this session is that
the department of health's view was that
testing had happened
um and that therefore it wasn't
necessary to do further testing in
england but i only know that from
what i've read
in preparation for today
so if we then pick matters up in june
um witn 3499020
um this is um a submission dated the 1st
of june 2015.
um it is um we don't need to go to it
but page 6 gives us the list of those to
whom it's copied and it includes um
your private office it's it's a
competition to mr jones um but we can
see it's addressed to um at the
parliamentary under secretary of state
for public health and the issue is
identified in the first paragraph is as
requested this submission sets out
options and estimates for using extra
money over and above the additional 25
million pounds already allocated in
2015-16
um and then the last sentence of that
paragraph says this would be contingent
upon additional money being agreed by
hmt
and cannot be met from within existing
dh budgets
paragraph two says secretary of state
has asked you to recommend a way forward
on this issue
so
is it right to understand from that that
there has that must have been some
dialogue or interaction between you and
and your minister yes
um and then paragraph three sets out
how a proposal to hmt and could be
formulated
um i don't i think at this stage i think
i need to go through the the the detail
of the options because again um the
options um
change um i think to some extent from
document to document but i want to pick
it up with
a letter that you wrote then at the end
of this month to the prime minister
so that's c a b o four zeros one six
three underscore zero zero three
it's a letter dated the 30th of june um
2015 um from you to mr cameron um and we
can see uh it's headed if we go further
down the page lawrence
response to the penrose report and and
you say this as you know this is an
incredibly difficult issue where we are
committed to giving a full government
response by the end of july
it is basically impossible to bridge the
gap between the expectations of families
who have suffered and are expecting a
settlement exceeding one billion pounds
and what we can realistically afford
time is also pressing as we currently
face litigation from three hepatitis c
sufferers or former sufferers who are
making the case that the current
arrangements favor hiv suffers over
those with hep c
legal advice is that some are likely to
succeed and if the dh were ordered to
recompense then we would face a
multi-million pound liability for
compensation for them and others in
similar circumstances
after considerable thought i'm writing
to set up what i believe our options are
and then we have three options set out
and i i just want to
read parts of this because um this is
obviously
a point at which you are directly
involved in in the decision making
process so the first option
is what you've described as the
austerity option 25 million pounds
this option sticks to the 25 million
pounds we promised before the election
with no additional resources allocated
for lump sum buyouts from the existing
scheme or accelerated treatment for
those with hepatitis c
and then there's
reference to the the current scheme and
being reformed
you pick up in the next paragraph on the
criticisms of the system
and say this the current system has been
widely criticized by those affected by
infected blood due to its confusing
structure discretionary charitable
payments and outdated funding structure
that proportions money to some who are
ostensibly well and little too many who
are ill
we would reform the system from five
funds to one single one which will
allocate money on the basis of impact of
infection on each person's health we
would also remind gps of the issue of
infected blood and their responsibility
to offer hcv testing to those at risk in
accordance with lord penrose's
recommendation
then we could use the additional 25
million pounds to offer final payments
to buy bereaved spouses and partners out
of the existing scheme currently only
about 10 of spouses receive regular
payments but under this proposal subject
to views following consultation
all surviving bereaved spouses would
receive a payment of around twenty
thousand pounds to exit the scheme
around ninety percent of barrie families
currently get nothing so they would
benefit but campaigners would be furious
and consider it a slap in the face
um
just
um if i can just ask you about something
in that second paragraph on on the page
you you talk about the system
apportioning money to some who are
ostensibly well and little to many who
are ill
i don't need to ask you i think about
the reference to little to many who are
ill because that i think is well
understood but
why was it thought by the department
that the current systems were giving
money to those who were ostensibly well
i suspect that is compensation to
families who've lost loved ones
rather than um
payments to support people who are
currently ill
in any event that's our first option um
that the department puts forward
and then the second option uh two is
minimum scheme likely to satisfy
majority of sufferers
and this would cost is this right an
additional 480 million pounds is that
how we should read this
correct
um
and then you say this given the
expectations set by the generous
settlement made in ireland for similar
issues up to a million pounds for each
family it will be impossible to satisfy
all families affected by this tragedy
but i believe the following scheme would
satisfy the majority of such families
payments will be offered not just to
bereaved families but to existing
sufferers in order to buy them out of
the scheme
payments would be around fifty thousand
pounds per bereaved family and up to a
hundred thousand pounds per infected
person
this option would close down the payment
schemes so whilst payment would need to
be tapered over the next five years
after this point no further funding
would be needed
and then top of the next page
additionally a new hepatitis c treatment
which can clear the infection has
recently become available the nhs has
introduced an accelerated treatment
program for those with greatest clinical
need
only around 800 of the infected blood
cohorts are eligible leaving two and a
half thousand with no early access to
the new treatment
under this option all two and a half
thousand would get accelerated access
this would be funded by us paying for
private treatment as we would not be
able to use nhs funds to allow them to
jump the queue ahead of other nhs
patients in greater clinical need
there is a risk in this option that it
would create a precedent for the dh to
be lobbied for funding treatments that
nhs england does not currently provide
but i believe this is manageable given
the exceptional historical circumstances
however although we are making progress
in identifying 22 billion pound savings
to the health budget we have not
completed this process so this option is
not currently affordable for dh and
would have to be funded by additional
resources from the center
so just to understand that second option
mr hunt
it would
require additional funding
480 million pounds
but the proposal is this right was
twofold
it envisaged essentially the winding
down of the schemes completely
and one-off payments and to as it puts
it to buy people out of the scheme
correct
and they're not and a treatment option
yes i'll come to the treatment option in
terms of the payments
they're not very
generous payments are they well it was a
i was making a judgment here and it's a
judgment that i fully accept people
might disagree with but i was
writing a letter to the prime minister
in which i was
trying to explain to him that
you know given i've been told in no
uncertain terms that there was no
possibility whatsoever of
of of
the treasury finding the
billion pounds plus that would have been
necessary for an irish scheme
if that was off the table
what
might
potentially
satisfy people as being not as generous
as ireland but
doing
a great deal more than we were currently
doing and i fully accept that it's
contentious as to whether that would
have actually satisfied people
as health secretary i i personally
had a priority to try and get treatment
to as many people who were ill
as quickly as possible
and there was this
issue that the way the nhs
for very understandable reasons
prioritizes treatment is on the basis of
clinical needs so the people who didn't
have the greatest
clinical need
well only 800 people would have got
treatment early so
got treatment automatically from the nhs
and i felt it was wrong that there were
1700 people who as a result of failings
by the state had an infection
that was life-changing and so
i wanted to allocate some of the
resources to that
and then the third option
is described as maximum possible within
dh budget constraints 125 million pounds
and you say this if we did not want to
proceed with the austerity option one
i've looked at what could potentially be
done within the very stretched existing
dh budget the advice i'm being given is
that very little is available
furthermore unclear if we were to find
additional resources it would take us
longer to identify the 22 billion pound
savings and perhaps most significantly
harder to balance our books in the next
two years when pressures will be
particularly acute
however i'm also aware of the need to do
the maximum we possibly can to bring
closure to a terrible tragedy that
affected around 4 600 people for which
they and their families have suffered
immeasurably so with the agreement of
yourself and the chancellor i would be
prepared to absorb an additional 100
million pound pressure in the dh budget
to fund accelerated access to the new
hep c treatment for all those in the
early stage of the disease
this would come from dh funds and would
not be funded to the nhs england mandate
indeed would be most likely to be
provided privately this additional
hundred million pounds will be on top of
the ongoing cost of the payment schemes
um so just pausing there again to
understand option three
this is
um on the basis that the schemes will
continue
essentially at the same
um
with the same level of funding that they
currently had
um leaving aside the 25 million pounds
that had already been found from the
contingencies port
and within the existing dh budget there
would be a further 100 million pounds
and your proposal in option three was
that that could be used for accelerated
access to the new hepatitis c treatments
yes um
let's be clear i the extra 100 million
pounds was
was a number that i plucked out of the
air it wasn't there wasn't any logic to
it in terms of the scale of the need
but because the spending review was
going to
take a further couple of years
um it was 50 million pounds it was the
the pot that i had
available for both the following two
years used up in its entirety for this
and um
[Music]
i thought it would be something not
remotely satisfactory but i thought it
would be something but i i had a
suspicion that the treasury were going
to say that they weren't prepared to
find anything for this so everything had
to come from the department of health so
this was the maximum that i judged that
we could afford
and at the bottom of the page you say we
should be clear that this option would
not satisfy campaigners so on that basis
you may decide to go for option one
anyway but my own view
is that notwithstanding um that it is
probably the fairest option to go for
given uh
current financial constraints
go on to say something about a public
inquiry but i'll come back to that later
so um
of three
options um
all of which were is this fair to say
imperfect in different respects
the
least imperfect in your view was option
three
well no my preferred option was not
option three my preferred option was
option two but it'd be made very clear
to me
as health secretary that i would have to
fund in its entirety
in any costs with any option
and we would have had to therefore take
that 480 million from the nhs's
frontline services budget which which i
didn't think would be right so
given that's why i say given current
financial constraints that's in a way a
code for saying given what the treasury
is willing to fund
uh on top of my budget
then i think option three is what we're
left with i see
um and then i
just want to look now at some documents
emanating from number 10 in relation to
this issue which is i understand it you
would not have seen at the time so
although some of the some of what was
being said would be fed back to you or
your private office the documents
themselves are not documents that you
would expect to have seen is that right
i think so yes
um so we can um start by
c a b o
four zeros one six three underscore zero
zero two
um and we can see it's from claire
mcdonald 5th of july 2015 to the prime
minister um i'll come back to what to
the handwritten um
entry in a moment let's just look at the
text
so it explains that
you have written to the prime minister
to outline the proposed next steps to
reform the system of support
uh and it describes you as having
outlined three potential options for
moving forwards with this which we've
committed to do before recess
um the next paragraph refers to the the
announcement in march the 25 million
it refers to campaigners having
highlighted the fragmented and
inconsistent payments
payment system of support we agreed that
we should look to consolidate and reform
these systems of support
and recently at pmq's you committed to a
full government statement in response to
the penrose report there's then
reference to the negative response from
campaigners to the penrose report
there's reference to the
um the one
recommendation and it said that that
will be accepted and and implemented
um and then there's reference again to
you um writing to the prime minister and
if we go over the page
and we can see in the second paragraph
it says the downside is that in order to
keep the overall cost of the scheme in
check
the consultation also proposes
withdrawing support from uninfected
family members such as widows of those
who've died following infection
this change would be a natural
consequence of prioritizing based on
clinical need
but will generate substantial opposition
the scottish government have made clear
that they will not join any consultation
where someone might lose as a result
that we expect a long delay before they
put forward on alternative plans
um and then
and that as i
as i understand it is a picks up on that
earlier consultation document that we we
looked briefly at
from from the end of 2014.
um and then
um
there's a summary of
um your three options
um in a different order in a different
order yes hence my confusion i think
earlier when i asked you a question um
and it says jeremy hunt favors option
three which was option two in your
letter which he thinks is fairest and
will close down the issue for future
years i think my letter did not say it
would close down the issue for future
years i think that's a
a
false inference from my letter
um and then we can see the number 10
view our view is that we should proceed
with option one so that's the austerity
option the 25 million already announced
and nothing further which is the only
option we feel is realistic in the 15 16
spending environment hmt will not agree
to a further 100 million from dh
underspends when hospital providers are
running deficits the hep c drug will
eventually be available um i think there
should be the word two there everyone
has nice has improved it but it's being
rolled out in a stage way jeremy's final
option of additional money from hmt is
clearly not feasible on top of the 8
billion of extra funding already agreed
with the nhs and then the question
that's posed for the prime minister are
you content to proceed with option one
publishing a consultation before recess
with the intention of using the 25
million to give lump sum payments to
surviving bereaved spouses of those
infected so we can see mr cameron's
response to that question is no
if we go up the page
um in relation to
the the the second paragraph and the
idea that um support would be withdrawn
from those who
already received it his comment is no
this will not work
and then if we just go to the first page
and just look at the handwriting there
i think i can read most of it so sorry i
don't think these work
a scheme that is meant to help but
actually takes money away from people
who currently get it is hopeless
and i accept we don't have 480 million
lying around
surely there is a route where we
increase
the 25 million to 100 million or some
such to fill in the worst payment gaps
and merge all the charities into one
which i think is ultimately is
effectively essentially what happens
um
do you agree with the characterization
by the prime minister of the the idea of
taking people money away from people who
currently get it is hopeless well um
he took a political judgment he may well
have been right i took a slightly
different judgment because within 125
million i wanted to
prioritize treatment and make sure that
everyone who had hep c
got treatment really quickly
so we made a different judgment in that
situation i understand why he made the
judgment he made and i think he is right
that there would have been a lot of
opposition from
the families that didn't get
uh the compensation that they were
expecting um so you know for me
the important thing about this response
was that he understood
uh that it would be
harsh beyond belief to stick with the 25
million and that we should as a very
minimum
do the hundred million
um
it was also clear that that he agreed
the national finances couldn't find the
480 million which obviously from a
health secretary's point of view would
have been what i would have hoped would
have happened but those were the the
constraints that i was operating under
and um if we go to witn three four nine
nine zero two one
we can pick up the communication of um
this from number ten back to your office
so if we go to the second page
and we can see in in the main part of
the page an email from will jones so
your private secretary um
sorry 6th of july 2015
um and it says the pm's looked at the
secretary of state's note on
contaminated blood and the proposed
consultation over the weekend and has
asked for a radical change in direction
and then we have the four bullet points
um
a very clear steer he's not prepared to
consult or not implement a scheme that
removes money from groups that currently
receive it
not feasible to spend an extra 480
million or request additional funding
from central reserves
um minded to progress with reform of the
charities
um but effectively level up the payments
with an and we can see an expectation
that the dh would meet that cost
and then no interest in pursuing the
option of accelerated hepatitis c
treatment so we can discount this option
for now
um
and then if we go to the first page
there's a concern expressed in the
middle of the page i don't know whether
this is from um um dh finance oh yes it
is it's from the director of group
financial management department of
health saying i'm still left with a
question on how this can be funded
and given with no resources to meet
these costs internally beyond the
one-off 25 million pounds and in for
2015-16
um so that that i think then
um
in terms of july
takes us to one further document
yes it's a further document from the
prime minister
and cabo
40164 underscore zero zero two
um so this is a a a submission a week or
so later um again from claire mcdonald
dated the 13th of july to the prime
minister um again we'll come back to
that the handwriting it says you asked
for a different approach to the
consultation on the form of support
schemes and it refers to the
consultation having been redrafted
um and then
um then the third paragraph says to meet
your request but also stick to the
timetable you committed to at pmq's the
consultation has been redrafted to make
it entirely open as to the best way
forward rather than specifying a
preferred government position
this delays decisions on funding for the
new scheme until the consultation is
complete there's no longer any reference
in the consultation to withdrawing
support from certain groups and the
consultation clearly states it's our
intention in reforming these schemes but
anyone currently receiving support will
continue to do so in a reformed scheme
and then over the page
um
there's a question about who should
announce this uh and the answer there is
given is
in terms of whether the prime minister
announced it no
um and then the consultation is likely
to raise expectations of significant
additional payments you initially
committed 25 million of additional
funding for new payments but this was a
one-off amount rather than the current
funding
and the next paragraph lenders will work
with the department of health and hmt to
a spending review timetable to consider
the affordability
i think
of is missing the new scheme and we'll
come back to you
with further advice
and then if we go back to the first page
and just look at the
handwritten entry
again as i understand it from mr cameron
this is better
um but totally unspecific and so will
disappoint
um and then sorry can we zoom in
laurence
he says we need to find thank you mr
hunt a sum of money and
um
our approach an approach that is
um a final one
no one is
expecting us to solve this but simply to
be a bit more
generous i think is what that says
um
so
um we we have that at the 13th of july
and then if we just complete this
exchange
by looking at a response
um within the department internally it's
witn
two
3499022
um this is um
again from mr jones to a range of
officials within the department um
and it explains that the prime ministers
consider the secretary of state's letter
again we now have a revised steer from
him
um
[Music]
and then i think we can just if we look
at the second and third bullet points
under the heading on scheme reform and
money
he felt something closer to but in
excess of the initial 25 million pounds
already identified would be more
appropriate he would like the policy
unit to work with dh with the aim of
identifying funding for this through the
spending review process
ideally coming out ahead of the final
outcome of dhs settlement if possible
and
then in fact under the next heading on
the consultation and written ministerial
statement at the pm accepts that
unfortunately the above will mean we
don't have a substantive response
ahead of recess
um so
the way in which you um
describe the outcome of this in your
witness statement mr hunt is
if we go to witn 3499001
page 50.
um paragraph 33.40 so near the top of
the page you say this my own
recollection
is that we ultimately settled on the
option of making an additional 125
million pounds available including the
sun publicly committed in march 2015
with the focus to be on increased
financial support rather than the
treatment focused approach that i put
forward the detailed options for reform
were to be consulted upon
and so it
ultimately following those various
exchanges it came to the situation where
you would find
in addition to the 25 million already
allocated the 100 million
but that 100 million would go into the
payments under the schemes rather than
accelerated treatment for hepatitis c
and that 100 million had to be found by
the department there was no further
money being made available by the
treasury is that right
um
so note the time i can pick up the rest
of the chronology i think after lunch
very good well let's um
take a break then now until two o'clock
two o'clock
mr hunt picking things up at the end of
2015
your statement tells us that in december
2015 there was the announcement
of the public consultation on the reform
of the schemes
you've set out the timetable in your
statement i don't think we need to go to
the underlying documents just in terms
of dates the consultation ran
between january and april 2016
and then the results of the consultation
and the government response were
published in july of
2016. um i just want to pick up a couple
of documents arising out of of those
events
um
first is at witn 3903006
if we go to the second page
we can see it's another minute from
claire mcdonald to the prime minister
dated the 5th of july 2016
and then
it refers to the introduction of the new
scheme and it says in the first bold
paragraph the department of health are
ready to announce a new generous sorry a
new more generous compensation scheme
for people infected with contaminated
nhs blood products
the details are set out in this note for
your agreement
if you would like to announce this 125
million pounds of new investment you
could do so at pmqs on the 20th of july
or dh could put this out themselves more
quietly
and then i don't think i need to go
through the detail of it but there is a
description of
main features of the new scheme
and if we just go to the top of the page
and just look at the
handwriting from mr cameron again
um
i'm not quite sure what the first word
is but something thanks
thanks good work
um i
would like to announce it
um
it
is less
it is less than the sufferers want but
without my intervention this would not
be happening so let's go through it
do you have any observations i've been
asked to ask you on on what's set out
there
um well
you know he did make the decision
to go for that middle option the 125
million not the 25 million option that
his number 10 officials
advised him to go for
um and so i think it is true that
you know he did make an intervention
to increase it um but i think he that
note also
demonstrates that he
understood that it wouldn't be
the solution that people were looking
for
um and and i again i think picking it up
from from dates in your statement those
that plans were announced by the prime
minister
in july 2016.
now there was then
we've explored details of the schemes
with other witnesses so i'm not going to
go through the detail of of how the
scheme changed and the payments with you
mr hunt but um we know and you referred
to it in your statement that there was
then a later consultation
in the spring of 2017 and that was about
something called the the special
category mechanism
um
and again i'm not i'm not going to take
you to the detail of that
and but there is just one thing i wanted
to
pick up with you
um
from that time
it's cabo 4010
this is a letter from the 20th of
february 2017
it's from um lord o'shaughnessy and
parliamentary under secretary of state
for health and the laws to amber rudd
the home secretary
and we can see the heading as infected
blood
reform of financial and other support
and it says i'm writing to seek home
affairs committee agreement to publish a
new consultation
and then it explains it
it follows the the earlier consultation
what's the
reason for having to seek home affairs
committee agreement to undertake a
consultation
um because
for domestic policy um there's a
subcommittee of the cabinet which is the
home affairs subcommittee which amber
rudd chaired
which would approve things that were not
deemed necessary to go to full cabinet
and then if we can go to the third page
and we can see the heading
collaboration with devolved
administrations
it says the consultation response
relates to scheme reform in england only
and then it says this scotland announced
its own scheme reform in march 2016
it'll be for ministers in wales and
northern ireland to decide how to
provide for beneficiaries within their
jurisdictions
the government in wales is considering
the outcome of a survey to those
affected by the infected blood tragedy
in wales to inform its decision on
infected blood reform from
2017-18 the government in northern
ireland announced on the 22nd of
december 2016 that it plans to replicate
the english scheme as have been
announced july 2016.
so we we can see
from this as as from other documents
that what had been a uk wide scheme with
the the various
alliance house organizations
um dealing with individuals from
england wales northern ireland and
scotland
became
ford evolved schemes
and it's right to understand i think
that the decisions that we were looking
at before lunch in relation to payment
and so on
and the consultation
refer to the english position only
i believe so
um
uh
do you have any
um
understanding of
how
um
it was determined that what had been a
uk-wide system would become four
national schemes
i'm afraid i don't i should know but i'm
afraid i don't
um um and then can i ask you to look
next at a letter from diana johnson mp
to to lordo shaunicy
um it's c g r a
zero zero zero one zero three one
um
so
this is at third of april 2017
and uh she says this in the first
paragraph i'm writing as the co-chair of
the appg on hemophilia and contaminated
blood
to express my concerns about the planned
reforms to the english reformed support
scheme for those affected by the
contaminated blood scandal
please also consider this my formal
response to the department of health's
consultation on special category
mechanism and financial and other
support in england
she then refers to
the government announcement of of the
support scheme in a written ministerial
statement in march
and then says this i will set out three
concerns about the proposals um as they
stand and i just wanted to ask you about
about that her first concern
is expressed in these terms firstly and
most crucially
i feel that the consultation neglects
the fundamental issue which lies at the
heart of all of the concerns raised by
appg members it is this
whilst the government has recognized
clear needs which need to be met within
the affected community it is not willing
to put enough money forward to meet
these needs
was she right in your view
yes
um
she then um sets out a number of other
matters in relation to that which i
don't place to ask you about if we go to
the second page
bottom half of the page
her second concern
is in the
penultimate paragraph where she says
secondly
i must express deep concerns about the
uncertainty over the future
discretionary
budget um and then
um she
uh um it talks about the um consultation
document and the impact assessment
and then
in the bottom of a few lines talks about
some parliamentary questions that she'd
asked about
um what was meant in in real money terms
for those affected
uh continues the department of health
clearly has a figure on what these cuts
will mean and i would be grateful
if you could provide it as a matter of
urgency
and
are you able to provide any any views on
the second concern about the uncertainty
over the future discretionary budget
i'm afraid i'm not um i don't i'm not
really aware of what that issue is about
okay
and then the third concern i think is a
is a more straightforward one so if we
look further down this page at the
penultimate paragraph
she says this finally
i write to reiterate my long-standing
concerns about the lack of support for
the bereaved
many of the bereaved understandably feel
that with a smaller discretionary fund
than promised they'll receive less than
they had before
the small ten thousand pounds ongoing
payment which is now being paid out of a
scant reprieve from this and as stated
earlier many widows have fallen short of
the strict eligibility criteria for this
and then she continues in the last
paragraph to say i can only reiterate my
strong feeling that until more funding
is announced i regret that the
government's proposals will continue to
rightly attract huge concern
and a considerable level of worry
amongst a group of people affected
through no fault of their own
um
do you
um
or what is your view on her concerns
about the support for the bereaved and
the adequacy of what was proposed in
relation to the bereaved
well i think i made it clear in my
advice to the prime minister uh
before in the letter that you
uh
showed up that i didn't think that the
125 million would satisfy campaigners i
didn't think it would
close the issue it was uh
a small step in the right direction but
only a small step in the right direction
and i think this demonstrates that point
um that
you know it was very much unfinished
business
now um
what resulted
obviously were were the the four
national schemes or the four devolved
schemes um and a lack of parity between
those four schemes so the inquiries
previously heard there were
things available in scotland that
weren't available in england wales and
northern ireland and and
things available in wales that weren't
available in england scotland and
northern ireland and so on
um were there any discussions to your
knowledge at a departmental or
ministerial level about the
the
the four schemes and what could be done
to ensure that there was parity between
them
not at my level um there may well have
been at a junior ministerial or an
official level
um but um
unfortunately i think that's something
that we had no control over
legally because of the devolution
settlement it's not
logical at all but something that was a
uk-wide issue that
happened when uh the nhs
throughout all four nations was run
uh by the uk government but that changed
in 1997
and so we
genuinely didn't have any control
i could imagine a situation in which the
four nations decided to act in concert
with a single scheme
uh i don't know whether that was
explored or not
but they weren't the best of relations
at a political level because um
england wells and scotland being run by
different political parties
so i don't believe any of those
discussions happened
um
would you agree that they're
bearing in mind as you say this was some
these were events that had happened
across the united kingdom
pre to pre-devolution
and
that there should not have been
significant disparities between what you
might get in scotland and what you might
get in england wales or northern ireland
when you've suffered the same
same loss
um
yeah i could use the words there should
not have been a difference but um
you know there was a conflict between
two different things that we as a
country had democratically decided one
was the devolution settlement which did
give
scotland wales northern ireland genuine
autonomy over health matters and so
we wouldn't have had an ability to
impose a single scheme across the united
kingdom
um
can i then just
flag up one further submission
which is at dhsc-0050103
um if we go to the third page
and this is a submission of the 12th of
september 2017
and we can see the issue
uh and says number 10 has responded
saying that they want the uplifts to be
funded from dh's existing budget without
additional funding from hmt
and to publish by the 14th of september
and we can see a discussion in the first
four paragraphs
um so it's said in the paragraph one in
response to a submission setting out
reforms to the infected blood payment
schemes you ask the infected blood team
to consider options
if the payment scheme funding envelope
was increased
and then paragraph two you and the
secretary of state agree that discussion
should be held with number 10 to explore
options to reinstate annual payment
uplifts from 2018-19
previously announced in 2016 but not yet
implemented
and to increase the overall level of
discretionary funding available an
additional four to 22 million pounds per
annum would be required from hmt as
finance colleagues confirm that dh does
not have the money for this
and then three
number 10 confirmed that they would like
to see the additional funding from dh's
existing budget
the dh finance team are working to
identify the funds in the existing
budget and then if we go over the page
to paragraph nine
which is the fourth paragraph on the
page into the heading finance
um number ten requirement to deliver all
components of the 2016 scheme from
within existing dh budgets results in
unfunded costs from 2018-19 for the
remainder of the spending review in
which existing commitments outside of
the nhs mandate substantially exceed the
funding available options will be
presented to the secretary of state on
the options for cutting other budgets in
order to support delivery of the number
10 infected blood commitment
and now it would appear from this and i
think
um
you um
or your office may have been copied into
this but it was obviously not addressed
to you
but it appears from this that
again
the department was being told it had to
find any additional money for the
uplifts they're described
from within its own budget
no extra money is available from the
treasury correct
as far as you can recall
um
during the time you were dealing with
this issue of the the the payment
schemes
was any additional money ever
forthcoming from the treasury no
were any
um
uh um written cases ever submitted to
the treasury for
um for consideration or was it more a
question of don't even go there because
the answer will be no
it wasn't quite don't even go there but
in a way we had a
a very i mean we knew that the
treasury's answer would be no so our
only chance of them changing that would
be if number 10 decided the answer
should be yes
and we did have very regular
communication with number 10
um
in which we essentially asking number 10
if they would uh support us in asking
the treasury for
additional funding but as you saw from
the early exchanges with
number 10 uh the answer always came back
exactly the same that this had to be met
from dh's existing
funding requirements i mean the national
finances were under very great pressure
um you know we had a huge deficit
um and at the time of that
memo i i do remember it was the time
when the
dhs finances were at their worst ever um
we had i think
from memory
something like a billion pounds of
savings that we needed to find over the
financial year in order to get the books
to balance and we didn't know where it
was going to come from and
you know i basically negotiated
the following june a 20 billion pound
rise in the nhs
budget if i if i hadn't been able to do
that
we would not have
we would not have been able to um
balance our books
and just so that we can understand what
um what's being said in paragraph nine
there um the reference to the nhs
mandate is that effectively the ring
fenced monies correct um to provide for
essential essentially nhs services yes
which you know was about uh 70 or 80
percent of the money that
came into the department of health went
straight to the nhs
um
under and the legal uh document was the
nhs mandate that was what we asked the
nhs to do with the money
um so but by the time
you left office in in in 2018
is this right
there wasn't
the new scheme
an english scheme now rather than a uk
wide scheme
in terms of additional funding
um and leaving aside what additional
funding might or might not have been
made available in relation to the uplift
issue here
there was the 125 million which was
found within existing departmental
budgets nothing nothing from the
treasury correct
um
when
i think it was john major gave evidence
to the inquiry
he used the analogy in terms of
government decision making of a of a
tanker a super tanker and the length of
time it can take to get that super
tanker to to change change direction
um it might be said it took an awfully
long time
to
from
2012 2013 when those first submissions
from 2013 were looking at
the schemes
to get to
the replacement english infected blood
support scheme
2017-2018
with very little additional
um
funding
yes it took too long and i think when
you look at the
anguish that
families are facing
but actually the simple fact that people
were dying
without getting access to the additional
compensation for their families
or
support that they needed
with their lives
you know i don't think anyone can be
proud of
the performance of the british state
over the last 25 years
but during the period i was in office
and this is
not to excuse it but
the bottom line was that there was a big
financial issue and we had a huge
national deficit and
so
you know it was like
we were trying really hard to do
something but we just didn't have the
ability i'm talking about from the
department of health's point of view we
didn't have the ability to do it and
as someone who um
cared a lot about patient safety issues
i was able to you know commission a
second francis report after mid staffs
that report into malcolm bay
the ochenham report into shrewsbury and
telford
um
the gospel report
and i was able to make progress in a
number of other areas but it was
immensely frustrating that in this area
because
the quantum of money involved was
billions
not hundreds of millions and i just
didn't have that at my disposal
progress was i mean i think you could
only describe it as painfully painfully
slow um and it it might be said or it
might be a submission that's made to the
inquiry in due course that
um
even with the changes that were made
what um the scheme that
emerged at the end still
fell
a very long way short of addressing
the injustice to to use a phrase that
you you've used
well i that's my view yes
can i turn to consider the question of a
public inquiry
and pick that up in your statement
and so if we could go back to
witn 3490
and if we could go to page five please
um and and paragraph 0.4 at the bottom
of the page
you say this
um
uh when i did become health secretary it
was made clear to me that the treasury
would not support an inquiry because of
the potential cost to the taxpayer which
taking into account any decisions on
financial support which might follow
such as a recommendation for a
compensation scheme similar to that in
place in ireland could amount to
billions of pounds i did not therefore
pursue the issue and follow the official
government line in correspondence with
all campaigners
um
can you help us in understanding who
made it clear to you
that the treasury would not support an
inquiry
um this was uh conversations that i have
with treasury ministers and also
conversations that we've talked about
uh with number 10 as well
which
you know operated as
one with the treasury throughout my
entire time
as health secretary well except
certainly under david cameron and george
osborne's time so
it was just made very clear to me the
whole time that
any funding for this would have to come
from money received by the department of
health
um and
in terms specifically of of the
institution of an inquiry
um did you push back against that
before we get to 2017 did you make
representations and try and challenge
the line that was being given to you
well
basically
i knew
and number 10 and number 11 knew
that a public inquiry would be likely to
recommend
large
sums of money compensation
support for families that would have to
be funded centrally not from the
department's budget and the nhs's budget
so
that was why
because of the independence of an
inquiry
the power of an inquiry is that you know
as
you are very well aware the power of an
inquiry is that it's very difficult in
practice for a government to reject
any recommendations that are made by a
public inquiry it has you know does it
in enormous detail as you're doing
and its
recommendations have tremendous moral
authority
so
i think everyone understood that if
there was a public inquiry and it made a
recommendation of
you know whatever the compensation was
that would have to be funded by the
treasury and so
therefore
uh it was clear to me that number 10 and
the treasury would not support a public
inquiry but
i felt as i said to you before that
there was a very big injustice so i was
i was looking out if you like
for
when a moment might come
that that position might change
and um
it did come um
maybe we're going to go on
we'll come on we'll come on to that in
2017 but just to go back to my question
does it follow from what you've said
that in practice you did not push for a
public inquiry because
you were
confident in your own mind that that
would get nowhere i wasn't just
confident in my own mind i mean i knew
the answer was no if you look at all the
responses that we had from number 10
to the discussions about much more minor
improvements
that we
would make it was very clear
that
they believe that you know every penny
of support
to resolve this issue would have to come
from the department of health's own
budget
um
and then i think we can get a sense of
the government line that was then
promulgated on the issue of a public
inquiry in communications with
campaigners and individuals
from dhsc
6736736
now this is not a response from you um
it's a response that's been provided on
your behalf and i'm afraid this is a
looks like a draft letter so it doesn't
look as though
um
we can be clear as to who it's from and
but we can see from the first paragraph
somebody in any event is is replying on
your behalf and and it looks like we're
dealing with late 2012.
the third paragraph says this as i
expect you know
it has been the view of successive
governments that after all this time
there is no justification for a public
inquiry into the matters relating to nhs
supply contaminated blood or blood
products in england
the relevant facts are already in the
public domain
and then references made to documents um
being published in line with the freedom
of information act
now
it might be said mr hunt that
that that line and we
we've seen it in earlier documents we'll
see it in later documents
was disingenuous
because from what you said the real
reason for not holding a public inquiry
was the concern that it might lead to
recommendations for the payment of
compensation which the government didn't
want to have to find
i'm i
i'm not trying to defend that line it's
wrong
and that is the kind of group think that
was in the government that basically
said that
this scandal happened because you know
good people were trying to do their best
something terrible happened it wasn't
anyone's individual fault
um and
you know and and therefore
when it comes to compensation the matter
is closed that was the view of
successive governments and indeed
we didn't have any reason
to
uh
to think that
uh
you know some of the stories that we've
heard subsequently that uh
the clear evidence that people were
being infected was overlooked by key
people at the time in the 1970s and 80s
i felt that irrespective of whether
whether
people have been deliberately infected
more compensation should be paid because
this was a terrible thing that had
happened and it was an injustice
in its own right um and so that was my
basis for wanting to see if there were
ways that we could get more compensation
and more support to the families
um but that is the sort of
i suppose the legal line that because
uh and
my own belief but you're going to come
to this conclusion your inquiry is that
it's wrong but
um my own belief is that um that it's
not correct but it was the public line
and i didn't have any
reason not to
i didn't have any reason to deviate from
that and indeed i was obliged to follow
collective responsibility as a
health secretary even though as you know
i personally felt that we needed to do
more and just so that others listening
can can understand that that reference
to collective responsibility
is that the convention that as a cabinet
minister you publicly articulate a
government line
and if you
are not willing to do that you resign
yes and that means that you have to
publicly defend lines
that you privately have argued against
so you know
at
this time i thought the nhs needed more
money and i was arguing for more money
and i was writing to theresa may asking
for more money for the nhs
but if i've been asked on the andrew
marsh show has the nhs got enough money
i would have had to say yes because that
was the official
line as agreed by the whole of the
cabinet now that might sound
wrong
but that's actually the way government
has to function that you agree something
as a group of people and you all defend
that line until
that group of people in the cabinet
decide something different
it is sort of the way it has to work for
government to function
can i just ask you to look look at again
at the letter you wrote to mr cameron in
in june 2015
cabo
40163 underscore zero zero three
we looked at the detail of of what they
said in terms of the issues regarding
financial support but if we could go to
the last page
you say this in the in the second
paragraph in terms of handling i would
suggest a normal statement by jane
ellison launching the consultation on
scheme reform and responding to the
penrose recommendation i do not propose
to publish a substantive response given
that this was a scottish inquiry in
scotland do not intend to respond and
then this
should there be calls for a further
inquiry in england i recommend that they
be rejected as all our documentary
evidence will be in the public domain
very shortly and further inquiries would
hinder scheme reform
now this isn't a public document or a
letter to a campaigner this is you
writing to the prime minister
if it was your view that there should be
a public inquiry
why were you recommending to the prime
minister that such calls should be
rejected because at that stage it had
been made very very clear to me that any
additional funding that a public inquiry
might decide was necessary would have to
come out of the nhs budget and we had
completely run out of money in the nhs
and because i knew
that was the very clear position of the
government at that time
um
then i didn't know where we could
possibly find the money
that would have been uh recommended by a
public inquiry
when
i was able to get the prime minister to
agree to public inquiry it was without
the caveat that the money would have to
come from the nhs's budget or the
department of health's budget
and so
that's why i was able to recommend it
and you know i was obviously delighted
when theresa may agreed to it
so if we move then to 2017 because i
think prior to
2017 the line continued to be
from the department of health and from
the government
no no need for a public inquiry and
i don't think we need to go to it but
there's there's a i think a letter you
wrote to diana johnson and there's
correspondence between vaughan gethin
the welsh minister and
and the department in which that line is
is essentially maintained
um
but then um you say this in your
statement so if we could go to witn
349900 one
oh sorry lauren's page six
it's the second paragraph 0.6 i'm just
going to read it out and then i
understand there might be a slight
correction that needs to be made to the
beginning of the paragraph so it reads
in 2017 just five weeks after the
conservatives have been returned to
office but having lost their majority
prime minister theresa may was going to
have to respond to a parliamentary
question on the issue
i sensed an opportunity to change the
government position i have no doubt that
it was because of the impression made on
me by mike duracot over many years
i had felt unhappy about the government
position throughout my time in office
and thought this could be the moment
with the government distracted and
weakened by the election result to
secure justice
i knew that from her response to the
hillsborough families as home secretary
theresa may had a strong sense of duty
to those whose voices were shut out by
the system but do not know if she
consulted the treasury before making her
decision to hold a public inquiry which
to her great credit she did
now i i understand that there may be a
slight correction to make to that or
something to add to the first part of
that paragraph yes i think it was not so
much theresa may having to respond to
parliamentary question but
uh to a parliamentary debate
um that
would have
been something potentially the
government would have lost
and um
you you say you sensed the opportunity
to change the government position
um can you just help us understand a
little more what you mean by this
so i thought that this was unfinished
business that we needed to give more
support to the families as i said here
you know
mike doracott who very sadly died at
this stage um was in my mind and um but
i also knew that it had been
consistently
blocked by the treasury because of the
potential cost implications
and here was a parliamentary situation
which the government was going to have
to respond to i don't remember exactly
what the motion was in parliament and
whether it was a i don't think it was a
binding motion but there was something
the government was going to have to
respond to
and i had dealt with theresa may
over the hillsborough inquiry which we
had both
worked on together and um
she was a very strong supporter of the
hillsborough families
and i knew that
she had a very strong sense
of the importance of securing justice in
these kinds of situations
um so and i think that uh
diana johnson deserves enormous credit
for creating that parliamentary moment
that allowed me then to make the
argument to number 10 we really should
have a public inquiry it's the right
thing to do
and then to my
delight
the answer came back yes
without any reference to the treasury
now when the prime minister's decided
something the prime minister's decided
something and it goes ahead
and i don't know whether
the treasury were involved in that
decision or not
but
it was a a very very important
breakthrough
and just to look at a
a handful of documents in relation to to
the
um the decision finally to hold a public
inquiry if we start with dhsc-0050
um 7th of july 2017 so this is a
submission it addresses in part the
question of funding options but also the
question of whether there should be an
inquiry and if we turn to page three
please laurence
we'll see the heading b inquiry and then
it says this at paragraph 12
to date the department of health's
position has been that another inquiry
would not be in the best interests of
sufferers in their families
as it would be costly delay action to
address their concerns and would curtail
plans to reform the existing support
schemes
the department's published a relevant
information that it holds some blood
safety in line with the freedom of
information act 2000 there have also
been two previous inquiries the archery
inquiry and the penrose inquiry in
scotland
now
i understand these aren't your words
because this is a submission produced by
officials but i just want to unpick that
first sentence a little
and
from what you said
the department's position or perhaps
more broadly the government's position
was indeed against an inquiry because it
would be costly
but it's difficult to see how that could
be said to be not in the best interests
of sufferers
well i don't think that that that
paragraph was written by officials
and um i don't
think it's
uh
i think ministers have to take
responsibility for everything that
happens in in their department so i
would never blame any individual for
that but i don't think it's a very
accurate representation of what the real
score was um i think it is true to say
that um a
there is always a risk in an
inquiry in a public inquiry that the
government can use a public inquiry to
kick issues into the long grass because
they take several years
and so
it is a reasonable point to make that
there is a risk in a public inquiry that
this happens although
in this inquiry you know i know that you
are considering whether you make
recommendations for interim payments and
sir robert francis has
um published his views on that so it
doesn't have to be that the case but
there is a risk of that so it's not
wrong to say that
but i think the real reason why the
department of health's position was
against the public inquiry was because
they thought that the costs
of any
compensation that was decided by a
public inquiry would have to be met from
the nhs's budget and that was that was
the heart of it
and then if we look at paragraph 13
um it says however victims remain of the
view that there's been a cover-up and
are not satisfied by previous inquiries
recent events including the announced
inquiry into the grenfell tower fire and
recent media articles on infected blood
have increased the pressure to hold a
public inquiry
and then there's reference to andy
burnham who the inquiry heard from and
hit the um speech he gave during a
german debate
calling for a public inquiry
um
and i want to just
look with you at some other materials
that were being published at around this
time but before we do that
we can see if we go to
i think page five will suffice
and we can see in the conclusion
in the third line you are also asked for
a decision on whether to hold an inquiry
on infected blood and although we don't
see from this version of the document
who this is addressed to
is it right to understand that the u
here
is the chief of state
um yes i don't remember if i saw that
document um and uh but i think what is
important about that document i mean it
looks like a a real document so what is
important is that despite the fact that
the department of health for many many
years
had been saying we can't have a public
inquiry
here is a document being written by
officials for ministers
as to
what they need to think about if they're
going to change that position so i think
it's very clear that there was a sense
at the time that ministers might say
we do want a public inquiry
and
then we need to be
you know knowledgeable about the facts
so that we uh know what we are asking
for and and know what we're going to get
and i just want to look at a media
report and a couple of parliamentary
reports um from that those that first
week or so in july just to understand
what role they may have played in in in
the process
so if we go first of all to mdia
40184
um this is an article published mail
online
um
the headline speaks for itself nhs
tainted and blood shame but we can see
the date is the third of july
and then um there is reference to
uh patients being given deadly
contaminated blood for at least five
years after health officials became
aware of the danger damming documents
reveal
reference to newly unearthed minutes and
then
reference in the last paragraph
to
a major civil action to be lodged at the
high court today in which 300 families
of victims are suing the government and
then the article continues over the page
i'm not going to
invite your comment on the specific
allegations mr hump but it's fair to say
that
the department would have known
um first of all
of this article or articles of of this
kind
but would have known from this um um
that there was also anticipated
litigation
yes i think they would have known there
was anticipated litigation through
sources other than
the website yes
i'm sure that's right it's just a
convenient mechanism for showing it to
you
and then if we go to
um rlit
301160
um we can see this is diana johnson and
to whom you paid credit a few minutes
ago fourth of july 2017.
um and it's a and described as a point
of order and it says this in his final
speech in the house the former right
honourable member for lee that's andy
burnham made the very compelling case
that there was evidence for criminal
acts having taken place during the
contaminated blood scandal which was of
course the biggest treatment disaster in
the history of the nhs
given that the criminal act that
allegedly took place is set out on the
front page of today's daily mail is it
appropriate for the secretary of state
for health to come to the house and say
what action he intends to take
the former right honourable member for
lee asked the secretary of state to
indicate whether he was minded to set up
a public inquiry into what happened
and said that if that did not take place
he would notify the police of the
evidence he had in his possession
so
it would appear that as at early july
2017
there is pressure from a number of
sources
the media
litigation
parliament and indeed mr burnham's
threat to take matters to the police
would it be fair to infer that those all
played a part in the thinking of the
department and in your seizing the
moment in the way that you described um
yes but i think that if i was going to
sort of
say what
had the the biggest impact i think it
was
uh probably not so much the media
coverage
because
the department of health is always
dealing with
uh unfavorable media coverage i'm afraid
that's sort of fact of life in that
department
i think the threat of legal action
in terms of
you know what's described here is
criminal acts
the department would have taken the view
well that is a matter for the police and
if there's evidence of that then
you know we'll cross that bridge when
the police bring a prosecution
um
i think the real
thing that caused if i can put it this
way the goal to be open
was
the threat of losing a vote in
parliament which was subsequent to this
when the speaker said that he would
allow
a debate
and i think that was really what allowed
me to go to theresa may and say
look i think this is the right thing to
do and and this is the moment to do it
and we can see it at rlit 000-1161
diana johnson's proposal on the 10th of
july 2017
that there should be
a debate on that very issue the
establishment of an independent public
inquiry so that's what you were
referring to correct
um
we know
um
if we look at cgra00011119
[Music]
and we know from the first paragraph um
that you
decided that you were minded to hold an
inquiry and the date of that is the 10th
of july 2017
and we can see it from the first
paragraph
and then it says in accordance with the
ministerial code he would like to
consult the prime minister for her views
and then that is the process that was
undertaken with theresa may agreeing um
to the establishment of an inquiry
and
can i then just ask for your observation
um
now on a on a different document w
that's sorry an earlier document witn
3499029
and this is a document
addressed to the
parliamentary under secretary of state
for public health and to you
um it stated the fourth of july 2014 so
it takes us back three years um but
you'll see the relevance i hope from the
title contaminated blood transparency of
the historical record because as we've
seen part of the the line that was taken
by the department was to say well we've
placed documents in the public domain
under the freedom of information act and
therefore we don't need an inquiry
and i just wanted to ask will you have
any comments on paragraph three
[Music]
it says this
preparation of records for release is a
time-consuming and manual process the
process ensures that the right
information is released to the public to
avoid challenges and penalties
and then this the cabinet office has
asked departments to ensure that
information is not unintentionally
disclosed which might open the
department to litigation or penalties
now that might suggest something less
than a transparent
totally agree i mean i don't think i saw
this document
and
it seems to me to be completely against
the point of freedom information act
and completely against
the standard of transparency that all
governments should aspire to i mean you
know if
the government is
become subject to litigation because
these things come into the open well
that's something the government has to
cope with but i don't think that should
be a reason for not releasing things
into the public domain
um
so the prime minister's announcement of
the inquiry was on the 11th of july
2017.
um
she made a handful of observations when
she made the announcement i'm afraid i
don't have the text of it on screen but
i'm just going to as it were repeat them
to you
and i'm not asking you to comment on
what the prime minister's view might or
might not have been but just to see
whether this reflects your own thinking
um
she described it as i recall as an
appalling tragedy which should simply
never have happened would you agree with
that yes
she described thousands of patients
being failed would you agree with that
she said that victims and families
who've suffered so much pain and
hardship deserve answers as to how this
could possibly have happened would you
agree
she said they've been denied answers for
too long yes
and that they should finally get the
answers and justice they had spent
decades waiting for yes
now in terms of
the inquiry being
established or the decision to establish
it being taken finally in july 2017
it's
it right i think to understand from your
evidence that it's this combination of
political and governmental
um pressures
um financial and financial pressures
that um
led to the decision
to establish the inquiry
put sorry i should have inserted the
word financial i didn't hear how the
sentence was ending um
there was no new piece of information
that came to the attention of government
was there that meant an inquiry now was
necessary when it hadn't been before
i mean
potentially this
allegation of criminal activity but i
don't think that was actually in the end
the significant thing no
would it would it be fair to say that
it's ultimately
the position that the government
announced an inquiry that could and
should have been established
years or decades before would
would that reflect your view
i think it is yes i i think it's
undeniable that this should have
happened you know decades earlier
and i think the question is
how it is that
it could have become kind of
established by the establishment if i
can put it that way
that
nothing wrong was done and um
and that line then religiously stuck to
by government after government and
the further away
that we got from those incidents
the harder it
came for
a succession of ministers to challenge
them because it just became established
as sort of
received wisdom as you could see from
the documents that you showed me earlier
but i do think it's a very big failure
of the state that
we didn't have more openness earlier on
and i
it's not for me to say this but i
sincerely hope that one of the things
that you will conclude as an inquiry is
is is understanding how we can prevent
that happening in the future on a
completely
diff apparently different set of issues
but essentially it was
i think it was a trying to
protect the reputations of people on the
basis that they were trying their best
which then led to a lack of transparency
about what happened and what mistakes
were made
um i just want to pick up
on a couple of matters relating to the
treasury and in in general terms i don't
think we need to look back at any of the
documents
it would appear from your evidence that
both in terms of
um enhancing improving extending the the
payment schemes and in terms of
establishing a public inquiry
the central stumbling block
or a central stumbling block was the
desire
not to um
use government money to pay for that
is that fair
uh
extra government money um yes and i
think look um
it's it's a difficult thing to explain
with the people in this room today but
you know the treasury's
job in some ways in government is to say
no to lots and lots of spending requests
that come from left right and center
that's
you know that's how they keep control of
the national finances and you know
we did face in 2010 picking up the
pieces from the biggest financial
collapse since the second world war so
it was a very difficult environment for
the treasury as well and the country was
in deficit um
in every single one of the years that
we're talking about so it was a
a particularly difficult period but
from my point of view responsible for
the department of health it was made
very clear to me that
um
any funding at all to resolve this issue
would have to come from
the department's budget which ultimately
would have meant the nhs budget
it might be said that
in part for the reason that you've just
referred to about the role of the
treasury that the treasurer is always
likely to take the line that it that
there isn't more money and it doesn't
want to provide more money to
departments
and
if there's a sufficiently strong will
across government as a whole
so leave aside the position of an
individual department
the money
can be found can it not and obviously
was found for at least for this inquiry
it was but in the end it took
the prime minister to decide to do it um
and
you know took the prime minister to
decide to require the treasury to
consent to it and
you know we did
get to that point in the end but it it
took too long
um
do you know whether
an exercise has ever been done of
anyone working out
um
how much could have been saved
ultimately if a proper scheme of
compensation had been established
in the late 80s or early 90s i'm not
aware of any such exercise
can i think just come back to a handful
of passages from your book um mr hunt
rlit0001163
um if we go to page four
i want to pick up on the theme of
transparency that we see set out um not
not quite halfway down the page but you
say my first instinct was to focus on
transparency
all these avoidable deaths felt like a
major scandal but one that no one seemed
to know about there seemed to be a kind
of a murder around avoidable deaths in
the nhs this was partly because people
at the top of the service thought their
political masters would not want the bad
publicity but it was probably more from
an understandable worry that talking
about such deaths would damage public
confidence in the nhs
unfortunately the corrosive consequence
of such thinking was all kinds of
terrible cover-ups in which both the
department of health and the nhs was
sadly complicit when problems like
mid-staffs were identified the default
response was to try and sort them out
behind closed doors without the public
ever finding out and then you talk
further about transparency in the course
of your book now
the inquiries
heard about the duty of candor
um in relation to
nhs bodies
what about
the duty of candor of government
of government officials government
ministers
well i think we do have a duty of candor
um and uh
that was why
with a succession of these tragedies and
scandals
um i thought the best thing was to set
up independent inquiries so um i did it
for
as we talked about earlier for morecambe
bay for
showsbury telford for gosport for
paterson
and i think very often um
the machine was very uncomfortable with
the fact that i wanted to keep setting
up
independent inquiries to get to the
bottom of what happened
because i
i became aware that
i couldn't ask the department to do
these inquiries because that would be
like asking them to mark their own
homework
and so you had to ask someone trusted
from outside to look into the issue
so
i did the other thing that i did which
was a
you know i think
probably the most important
change in transparency that i was
responsible for was to
set up the ofsted system for hospitals
gp surgeries and care homes so that an
independent inspector
went round
all of them rating them as outstanding
good requires improvement or inadequate
so that the public would know if the
care they were getting from an
organization was safe or not
and then i
published data on
surgery outcome rates by
surgeon and a whole bunch of other
things wherever i could i thought
i
came to realize though
just to give you a complete answer i
started by thinking it's all about
transparency i came to realize that
transparency on its own is not actually
enough
you have to then have a system where
there is the energy
and determination to change things on
the basis of the data that you get so
sometimes you can sort things out just
by transparency you know it shocks the
system into changing things
but sometimes even after you've
said the care in this hospital is poor
nothing happens and so you do need to
have a
an energy to sort out problems that goes
alongside that transparency
but if um
if transparency and
an ability to learn from mistakes
is important
for doctors and other healthcare
professionals and nhs bodies
is it equally important
for civil servants
and for government ministers
particularly in a department such as the
department of health it is um it's
more difficult in an adversarial
political system for politicians to say
i made a mistake because
you know someone in parliament will
stand up and say he just told us he made
a mistake last week how do we know he's
not making a mistake this week and you
get a lot of that yabu and you know in
my book i wrote a whole book about some
of the mistakes i made
when i was health secretary um and i was
actually surprised at
how i didn't get that response from
people people actually welcomed someone
who who tried to write objectively about
what happened
um
but i think that
with civil servants there's
there are two things going on which um
it's worth just unpacking if you'll
allow me to substitute i mean the first
thing is
um
this
desire
human desire really to cover up mistakes
or
to gloss over them
sometimes to protect your colleagues
um but you know it's it is a human
instinct but i think there's also with
civil servants a desire
to please their political masters they
are very conscious of the fact that they
are civil servants who work for elected
officials
so quite a lot of their advice
may sometimes subconsciously be
what they think their elected masters
want to hear so um
it may be that the civil servants
who were responsible for this area
actually did have their own private
suspicions that something terrible
happened in the 1970s and 80s
but weren't sure whether the politicians
would welcome something that would mean
billions of pounds of additional
liability
so didn't confront us with
those facts
it's not for me to make that judgment
it's for you obviously with your careful
examination the evidence to try to
understand that but i think sometimes
the problem in our system
is that
civil servants
don't
want to confront ministers enough with
difficult choices and
they can be too deferential and that may
have been a factor here too
and that's an issue you took but you
touch in your book i don't think we need
to put it go to the the pages but um
you touch both on
the the blame game in relation to
politicians and the difficulties of
in a parliamentary system potentially of
of owning up to mistakes and then that
issue about civil servants um and and
there being hierarchical constraints
potentially on on civil servants um
advising ministers
also in your book
one of the other topics you touch on in
the book and perhaps we will go to this
is page 28 please lawrence
is um group think this this chapter is
is entitled groupthink
and you describe it in these terms if we
look at the bottom half of the page
and so it's the paragraph beginning the
answer is patchily
um but picking it up in the second line
you say let's look in more detail at the
dangers of a consensus
becoming so well established and that no
one wants to challenge it and and then
you you discuss that further not least
in the context of matters relating to
the
um
decision making regarding covet can you
just
um
perhaps
elaborate upon that a little that idea
of
yes i mean i think the
the group thing that i
i found most troubling
was
this idea that um
harming
and killing some people
is inevitable in modern healthcare
systems it's just going to happen it's
the price of doing business
and whereas if we organize things better
we we should be able to stop all
preventable harm and death
and um
it
came home to me because um
and i mentioned in the book that a very
early conversation i had with the um
medical director of nhs england
professor bruce keogh who was a heart
surgeon and he described how one of his
patients died after one of his heart
operations
and he was very upset and his colleague
said to him bruce he had a bad heart
he was going to die anyway
and bruce said yes but he wasn't going
to die on tuesday
and
that for me is the
the problem with group think is that
you're you're trying to support your
colleagues who are going through
a stressful time
doing a very stressful job and
in medicine you know you're taking life
and death decisions
in a pandemic you might be taking a
decision which ultimately means who
lives and who dies if you're having to
decide who you're going to admit to an
intensive care bed and you haven't got
enough of them
and in that context people try to
reassure each other
and then they
understandably try to convince each
other they weren't responsible for a
death that they may have been
responsible for
and i think it's important to say that
in the vast majority of those cases
absolutely no one is to blame
but the result of that kind of group
think of this was going to happen anyway
there's nothing that could have been
done is that you don't then have a
proper
examination as to whether things could
have been done differently
and led to a different outcome and
that's the concern that i have and so i
think that um
you know there is that and i think that
might be a factor here and just before
we leave these extracts from your book
if we go to page 33.
you say at the bottom of the page
um when i left the department of health
after six years of focusing on the issue
of avoidable harm and death there were
still three outstanding inquiries
and then over the page
you identify those as gosport
and the cumberland review and the review
into maternity maternity debt at the
showsbury and telford hospital nhs trust
i've been asked to point out to you that
you you don't identify
this outstanding public inquiry and i
should have i mean it's a you know it's
obviously a very very important one um
but um
you know i
i
could easily have done it um and i
should have
can i then um
just ask you
in relation to the charity that
you set up patient safety watch
um if we could go back to your witness
statement please so witn 3499001
and it is
um
yes um
it's page 13.
now you refer in paragraph 4.2
to the establishment of this charity in
september 2019
um you explain about five lines down
that the research looks at avoidable
harm caused by day-to-day medical error
rather than that caused by
administrative or policy decisions and
and that you're not looking at
um
the issues with which this inquiry is
concerned but i just wanted to ask you
about what you say in the very last
three lines you say we do frequently
come across the tendency of modern
health systems
to underplay misrepresent or cover up
patient harm and death
so those themes that you refer to in
your book by reference to your time as
secretary of state for health
are themes that you have also
encountered
through
the work that patient safety watch
undertakes is that right
yes i mean um and that probably explains
why i didn't mention it as a
as a fourth outstanding inquiry because
my
focus in patient safety has been on
medical error
uh as in
decisions taken in hospitals by doctors
and nurses or indeed by gps
which have resulted in
harm or death that could have been
avoided rather than
what appears to have happened here which
was a
decision taken by
officials with respect to
a national policy approach to blood
products
and what patient safety watch does is it
simply commissions imperial college
london
to look at
that kind of medical error and to try
and quantify
the amount of avoidable harm and death
we have every year in the uk and they'll
publish their first piece of research
into that um in a few months time so
that's that's it's a slightly narrower
focus but the themes obviously overlap
and then if i could then draw your
attention to
a report of the health and social care
committee
and
two rlit000128 two
now this is a relatively recent report
april 2022
of the committee which you talked about
this morning which you chair
and we can see it's entitled nhs
litigation reform and it it's a fairly
lengthy report and i'm not going to ask
you to comment on on on the bulk of it
um
but one of the
themes that has emerged from the
evidence that this inquiry has heard
was a concern
on the part of officials and ministers
not to provide financial support because
of what was seen as a slippery slope to
no fault compensation
and and that that idea of of no fault
compensation or comp or compensating
people outside of court actions for
clinical negligence is
one of the central issues in in this
report
and
can you just tell us some
in a nutshell
what the conclusions were of the
committee in the report yes and by the
way we're not the first people to make
this recommendation i think so brian's
very
familiar with um
the approach that we took um from his
own
work on the bristol inquiry
but um
[Music]
i think there is a crossover in a way to
the issues you're considering here um so
the example that we give here is that
if a baby is born severely disabled
at the moment under the law
maybe the child has cerebral palsy
because of errors made in the birthing
process
the only way that the family can get
compensation is if they can prove
clinical negligence either by the
clinicians involved or by the hospital
and of course they desperately need that
conversation because they've got a
disabled child to bring up and it's a
you know that child will have a lot of
needs and so
you end up with a legal process that can
last between five and ten years
um and
you know then they might get a
multi-million pound settlement but they
didn't get the money when they needed it
most which was in the early years
and the doctors are incredibly defensive
in the process because
no doctor wants to be
accused or convicted of clinical
negligence
and the one thing that needs to happen
most of all which is to actually
understand why it happened because no
doctor would do this on purpose
learn the lessons change
uh
the procedures and spread the lessons
around the rest of the nhs
is the thing that doesn't really happen
and
in japan which one of the examples
we use in this they introduced no fault
compensation for children born with
severe cerebral palsy in
2008 or 2009
and
they have had a one quarter reduction in
children born with severe cerebral palsy
in that period so it's immensely better
much much cheaper
and
i think
last comment i'd say on this is that
when i was health secretary i was warned
we can't have no fault compensation in
the nhs because it would be too
expensive because the vast majority of
people who are harmed by the nhs don't
take the nhs to court but if you just
had automatic compensation from a menu
then lots you'd end up paying money to
lots of people who don't currently get
paid anything and that would end up
costing a lot
to our astonishment when we did this
report and that's what they do in new
zealand
when we looked at
uh what happens in new zealand
as part of the research for this report
we found that actually it costs half as
much as a proportion of all their health
spending in new zealand as it costs us
in the nhs in england so it is not only
much better for patients because lesson
to learn but it's also much cheaper for
the health system
and
finally um
from
me mr hunt for present purposes just two
questions
and the the first is this
your successor matt hancock when giving
evidence to the inquiry last year
accepted that there was a moral
responsibility on government to address
the impact of what has happened to those
infected and affected do you agree with
that yes
secondly
if we turn back to your statement please
witn three four nine nine zero zero one
and go back to
[Music]
page
five
um it's
what you say in the last sentence of
paragraph 0.3
and i just wanted to draw attention to
not least because i
understand that mike's family are
watching your evidence
you say this
it will forever remain in my conscience
that i did not come close to delivering
justice to mike and his family whilst he
was alive
and that remains your your evidence
yes and um
you know mike wasn't the only
person i met who was affected with
the contaminated blood
scandal
but
i think
it was universally agreed that he was a
wonderful man he was a very decent man
um
he could have been a lot angrier
than he was actually and he was someone
who i think understood
the constraints that
politicians operate under and he was
always
very gentle and very decent
so i
i did remember him
i don't think it'll be any
consolation to anne but i would say that
i think thanks to mike
and indeed
thanks to uh to melanie and steve and
other constituents that i met
i probably was the first health
secretary
who came into office with the sense
that this was something that was
unfinished business where justice had to
be done
and um
i was also one of a long line of health
secretaries
over
decades
who
wasn't able to resolve it at least in my
case until the very end
but what i would say is that
although in some ways
you could look at this as
a huge failing of our democracy that
it's taken so long to resolve this issue
i think in another way
the families and campaigners
including mike
were entirely responsible for justice
being done in the end by the way they
campaigned by the way they put
pressure on
all of us in parliament
and created that moment in which the
public inquiry
should happen
so i think um
in that sense uh
you know sadly posthumously
mike made a huge contribution to justice
being done
[Applause]
so those are the questions i'm proposing
to ask if we could now take our
customary break to allow
the legal representatives for core
participants to suggest any further
matters they want me to ask mr hunt do
you have any sense of how long it might
be i think half an hour should suffice
the normal half an hour break if we need
longer i will obviously let everybody
know well we will take a break until not
before
quarter to four
let me let me explain
um
the the act provides that those who are
core participants in the inquiry
and it means what it says participants
have a right to put questions
to a witness through council to the
inquiry
and plainly before they can decide what
questions they might want to ask
um they have to listen to your evidence
they will have read it
um
but they won't necessarily have heard it
and and be and have formulated their
questions as yet and they must be given
an opportunity to reflect and and do
that and cancel herself uh to consider
uh how best to put the the question
she's asked to do
so that takes a little while
uh it may take longer than half an hour
which is why i say not before
quarter to four if there is a delay it
will be told
everyone will be told
but um otherwise we start there thank
you sir
hunt this final set of questions won't
be in a particular chronological or
thematic order because they're that
they're specific points i've been asked
to to raise to a number of different
sources
um could we um go to please lawrence
dhsc
zero
this is really just a
potential point of correction to a
document
so we can see there's a date at the top
of the page 7th of july 2017
and i think that's the date that then
perfectly understandably appears in your
statement
if we go to page three
paragraph 13
we can see the last bullet point
refers to on the 9th of july the sunday
times publishing a letter to the prime
minister signed by the leaders of all
opposition parties calling for a public
inquiry and so i'm i'm really asked just
to point out that it may be that the
date of the seventh of july
or on this is inaccurate and it might
perhaps be um the 10th of july it's
obviously before the the announcement or
the final decision that's taken
um
so that that that's that um
we can take that down thank you
um
when i was asking you earlier about the
decision-making as regards of public
inquiry
you said that it was
um
the the the view
or the knowledge that an inquiry would
recommend large sums of money or
compensation that was a deterrent factor
does it follow that there was an
underlying acceptance within number 10
in the department that an inquiry would
be likely to find that there was
wrongdoing which would then point to
compensation
i don't know if that's necessarily true
um and i think that uh
you know we obviously all waiting to see
what you conclude in this inquiry
um
to me it seems likely that there was
wrongdoing
but i think the
view was that it would cost money anyway
because
irrespective of whether there was
wrongdoing
there had been
injustice and that's why an inquiry
would be likely to recommend
more generous support from families
than had been forthcoming to date
and
when we looked at
that those three options that you set
out in your letter to the prime minister
in june 2015.
an aspect of one of them was the
provision of accelerated treatment
um
so access to the new or their new
hepatitis c treatments and for those who
have hepatitis c as a result of in
infection through blood and blood
products
now we know why that option didn't go
ahead we've discussed that but was any
consideration given by you or to your
knowledge the department to
asking nhs england
to
structure the roll out of of the new
hepatitis c treatments so as to ensure
those infected at the hands of the nhs
and
accessed those treatments quickly
yes to my knowledge that was the first
question i asked could we just
treat
uh the people who've been affected by
this scandal first
but i was told that that wouldn't be
ethical
because essentially the nhs treats
people with the greatest clinical need
first
and so to give
accelerated treatment to people with
lower clinical need
would mean that people with a higher
clinical need who are unaffected by this
scandal would be deprioritized
and so
for that reason
if we wanted to accelerate treatment for
everyone affected by this scandal
curious that it might sound and i was i
did query it when i was asked it but the
only way to do that would be to pay for
the treatment to be given privately um
and so but i
still felt that
it should it didn't really matter how
you chose to skin the cat
you know we needed to get this treatment
done
uh quickly to people affected by this
scandal so i was prepared to support
that option even though it wasn't
ultimately accepted
um
and then turning to the decision making
in in july 2017 regarding um the
establishment of the public inquiry
was it the case and this picks up on
what you said in your statement about
a moment where the government was
distracted or weakened and you referred
to the diana johnson
debate was it the case that the
um dup had threatened to withdraw their
support for the government if there was
not a public inquiry
with
potentially then jeopardizing the the
government's ability to to remain in
power
not to my knowledge
um
you
used the phrase earlier about the
government not marking its own homework
should there be an independent body or
panel
able to order
independent investigations when there
are concerns about patient safety or
public health
rather than waiting for the secretary of
state to do so
it's an interesting question um i can
understand the logic for that i i
certainly think
that
the secretary of state should have
the ability
to ask for independent investigations to
be done
quickly and easily and there is
an organization that's now been set up
called the called hssib which is the
healthcare safety investigation branch
which
we set up in shallow form when i was
health secretary which theoretically
which can do safety investigations on
any issue it chooses
without reference to the secretary of
state
and so it
it can go without fear or favor and
anyone who gives evidence to those
investigations has legal privilege
um there has to be a court order before
any identities of anyone who gives
evidences is revealed so
we have moved in that direction
but i think the
the fundamental problem is a cultural
one which is um
that there's a sort of
blame culture which means that everyone
is frightened about being open and
transparent when there be mistakes
and so
the result is there's still
too much covering up going on and not
enough learning from mistakes and so
you know in a way it would be much
better to address that fundamental
problem of culture so that you didn't
need to have these independent choirs in
the first place because the system
self-corrected it was hungry to find out
where things had gone wrong
and and try to sort things out for the
future
and then looking specifically at
government and not the nhs
how can government be subject to greater
internal challenge do you have any
suggestions
it's a
really important um
question to answer and i think that um
there are
there are lots of things that one could
do i mean the first thing is that um the
it's very important the relationship
that a minister has with their officials
and i found that one of the problems in
my three cabinet jobs
was that ministers were often as we
talked about earlier a bit too
deferential
and
they were very keen to do what you asked
them to do but if you had an idea that
was completely balmy
they sometimes didn't tell you and
actually you really need people who will
say that's a completely mad idea
secretary of state and it won't work
because of this this this
and that doesn't happen as much as it
should
and
you need to have enough trust
and also people need to see enough of
you you need to have officials who are
in and out of your office every day so
they're very comfortable being around
you i used to prefer people calling me
by my first name
but a lot of officials found that very
difficult because it's quite a formal
structure inside the civil service
um so i think one of the things is to
build teams around you who are who
there's enough trust that you can just
talk very openly and say um you know
don't do this do that
and so on
um
but i think also
there is a role for transparency
um
[Music]
i believe we made some very big mistakes
in the first few months of the pandemic
and
one of the reasons was
that sage's advice to ministers in those
early months was wrong they
they recommended suspending testament to
test and trace program in the early
stages of the pandemic that's obviously
this matter for another public inquiry
rather than this one but the point is if
that advice to ministers had been
published in the public domain
then i think lots of other scientists up
and down the country would have said
there's something wrong here
and you'd have had scrutiny and
challenge
and we would have got onto the right
policy more quickly than we actually did
so i think transparency um does have a
role um but i think the most important
thing that
encourages a constructive culture inside
government is what we talked about
earlier which is just
moving away from this blame culture
where if you admit you did something
wrong you're going to get fired
which
is often not the case but people worry
it might be the case
and recognizing that
sometimes people are going to make
mistakes and and
you need to allow people the chance to
learn from their mistakes and grow
um in going back then to
the funding that was found within the
department's own budget so the 25
million from the contingency pot and
then the 100 million um
that you referred to
um is it right to understand that that
having been found from the department's
existing budget
that there was no consequential funding
for the devolved administrations
i don't know the answer i was trying to
think about that when you asked me the
questions earlier but i don't think
there was any consequential funding
because
that came from our
nhs budget for england
and the nhs budget for scotland and
wales and northern ireland have been
given to them and the the increases in
the nhs budget in england so when we
announced an extra 10 billion pounds of
nhs in england in 2015
that had consequential impact on the nhs
budgets for scotland wales and northern
ireland and that the additional money we
found came from
that money so i think the the barnet
consequentials that already happened
um
we talked about
what the department might have
anticipated from the penrose inquiry
um and my understanding from your
evidence was that it was thought that
the penrose inquiry might make
recommendations in relation to
or recommendations that might lead to
uh
financial payments
do you know what the basis for that and
anticipation was in the department was
that just an expectation that it was an
obvious thing to do or or was it based
upon some concrete information about the
course of the inquiry i don't think it
was based on any concrete information i
just think we thought there's an
independent inquiry happening in
scotland and that may well recommend a
much more generous framework for
families and
then we would
feel under strong obligation to do the
same in england and
you know we were a bit surprised when
when it didn't do that
um
the the next question to talk about
where money might come from within
government
and the question or the first question
is this why does it appear to be
automatically assumed within government
that any man is required for the support
of those infected and defected through
through blood and blood products
required to be treated as monies falling
within the ambit of the health budget
well
that that is the way that government
works so they would you know
the treasury's view would be
we give the department of health the
biggest budget in the whole of
government it's it's a huge
um strain on national resources paid for
by taxpayers so if there are any issues
that happen in that area
then um
you know
you have to consume your own smoke so
that would always be the default
um in any discussion and that they would
the treasury would say look um the time
we have discussions about how much we're
giving you is at the start of spending
reviews the three year spending review
periods
and then we'll have a big discussion
about
what you think the things are you might
like to spend money on but um outside
that
you have to find them on yourself so it
was it was the default position but in
fairness to the treasury it was also a
period when we had a massive hole in the
national finances the treasury
themselves were in
uh in deficit so it was it was a very
uncomfortable period for everyone
is a problem with that default position
that the government can
um
rebut
arguments for the provision of financial
support on the basis that that will come
out of direct patient care for others
well i said that on one occasion and and
the families were extremely angry that i
said it and and indeed i i said it in
parliament
because that was the
the uncomfortable reality of my position
that i knew that
um at that stage any additional support
would have to come from
from
the department of health budget which is
effectively
uh the nhs budget because that consumed
the lion's share of it
um
i think that
there's all the truthful answer your
question is that a prime minister can
decide any stage
that this is an exceptional situation
and i want it to come out of contingency
funding from the treasury
um
and um you know i think david cameron
showed a lot of
sympathy and as you can see from some of
the responses he gave to my letters
but he was also very conscious that the
national finances were in a terrible
state as well so
um
i think that was what made it very
difficult to resolve this
and then just picking up on that i
think i explored with you earlier that
the the idea that
across government if you look at it as a
government as a whole rather than an
individual department government can
find the money for things it wants to do
it might be at the expense of other
things but nonetheless it can it can do
that
would you accept that the decision
um to not find the extra money to
enhance the financial support schemes
and hold a public inquiry
was a question of won't not calmed
um
i think that's putting it too starkly i
think it was
very difficult of course it is true if
the government as we found for example
in covet we suddenly needed to spend 400
billion pounds
and uh we were
you know we found the money but we found
it by adding to the national debt
and
so
you know there are always consequences
to these choices
so
it is true that
if you want to find the money for
something as a prime minister as a
government you can
but there may also be consequences which
ultimately are consequences that
ordinary people have to face the
consequences of
in the end so i think
[Music]
that is what
made this situation
incredibly difficult um it was a
contributory factor to the thing that i
think is absolutely true that it took
too long for the state to resolve this
issue and i don't think any of us who
are in government
can escape our share of the
responsibility that it took too long
over successive governments
to resolve it so i've i've given you the
specific circumstances during
my period in office
but there were
there were other things that happened
much earlier and i think the totality of
this
was was a failure by the british state i
don't think there's any other way to
describe it
so those are the questions i'm proposing
to ask from the suggestions i've
received i'm just going to check with
miss gray no there's nothing from miss
gray
do you have any questions for mr um yes
i do
um
it is one way of describing what you've
said about the
the
difficulties there were in
establishing an inquiry that being that
government was worried about how much it
would cost
in the end or could cost depending on
what the inquiry recommended
does that contrast with the other
inquiries which you have
been involved in because health the
health service is full of inquiries
and
they've all been much smaller
yes so is is this really a reflection of
the sheer scale and size
of what is involved in this inquiry
partially yes
um
but the other inquiries that um
that i set up
uh weren't
i'm just trying to think but i don't
think there were public inquiries as uh
legally constituted the mid staffs
inquiry was but i didn't set that up
that was set up by
andrew lansley but then the
um the patterson review the cumberland
review
the um gus board gosport
the
malcolm bay
these were independent inquiries but
they weren't public inquiries and
um
and compensation wasn't
the principal issue in fact you know i
don't think it's the principal issue for
people here i think it's justice and the
truth that matters most
but
nonetheless in this case there was a
you know potential for a large bill as i
think was evidenced by
uh what happened in ireland which i
think was what was on the minds of
people when they were thinking about
whether to have a public inquiry with
respect to the contaminated blood
scandal
i mean one of the things which which
also i think
is reflected in the evidence which we've
heard from
those core participants
and participants who've given evidence
uh is their desire to learn the
government and the medical profession
and the administrative
bodies involved learn the lessons
of what has taken place so that it
doesn't happen
again or something like it
it doesn't happen again or if it does
that it is dealt with in a rather better
way
part of that of course
comes back to your suggestion that there
should be
a change of culture now
um
i've said this to one other witness
that
in the health service
over the years
of the last 50 years have been quite a
number of inquiries most of which
and i think mid-staffs is no
no stranger
have said that what needs to change is
the culture
um and you've said well what we need to
avoid the culture of
of blame
um
or perhaps we need to have a culture of
blame but rather than
blaming people for making a mistake
blame them for not admitting
that they made a mistake
[Applause]
how do we achieve that
well um
i think it's very well put if i may say
so brian um and i
uh when i introduced the duty of candor
uh following the francis inquiry
i
looked at this i i looked at the issuers
as to whether we should have the duty of
candor for
individual doctors and nurses and i was
advised no
that should be done in their
professional codes of conduct but the
legal duty of candor only applies to
hospitals and health care organizations
and
i
wonder whether i should have gone
further in that respect
because i think that
what is not the case at the moment i'm
talking this is
slightly tangential to this inquiry but
for an individual doctor and nurse i
think the price should always be higher
for not being transparent about what
happened
than for being transparent about what
happened which i think is exactly the
point
that you're making
so what i would say is that
all the inquiries that concluded while i
was secretary of state
i used them
to introduce measures in the health
service
that increased transparency and learning
from mistakes and they were practical
measures so for example from the francis
inquiry i introduced the ofsted rating
of hospitals gp surgeries and care homes
so that we know
where we get good care and where we
don't get good care
we introduced
the learning from death's program after
the issues
at southern health
we introduced uh
medical examiners or
the implementation of medical examiners
which had long been recommended
following the more convey inquiry so
there's every single inquiry that
reported i used it as a moment
to make changes that changed culture
and
um
what i would say is that i think it's
when if if you too conclude that culture
needs to change with respect to these
mistakes um i hope you might also think
about what the practical measures are
that can be done because i think it's
very easy for governments to say yes we
agree culture needs to be changed but
the next question is so what are you
going to do about it what's going to
change to make that happen and i think
that
there are things you can do and i when i
started as health secretary i ran a mile
from anything to do with culture change
because i thought this is too nebulous
you're never going to get anywhere and
then in the end i concluded actually the
only real change is culture change
because that's when you change the way
people think and that's when you really
change things forever
and i do think
that the nhs is more open and more
transparent
um you've been generous enough mr
richards to quote from my book
i don't think it would even possible
ten years ago for a former health
secretary to write a book
in which every single chapter talks
about a terrible
tragedy that's happened in the nhs and
what went wrong
and for people to read that and take it
at face value i think that we have moved
on and we do talk about things that went
wrong but there's still a very very long
way to go
well you you've suggested there that
if i were to say that as a
recommendation that the culture should
change in this or that respect
um the next question is how do you do it
um well that really was what i was
asking you
um
well i i have to be honest i've given a
lot more thoughts to this when it comes
to
um clinical practice by doctors and
nurses
and so i think that
we need to
so
we need to do the things that are
recommended in in that
litigation report that i did where we
need to move to no fault compensation
um but most importantly when it comes to
doctors and nurses i think
the law
needs to be strengthened
to recognize that there's a difference
between the ordinary human mistakes that
you and i make the whole time
and
unforgivable gross negligence
and um we need to understand that
doctors are going to make those human
mistakes too and sometimes people are
going to die as a result of those
mistakes and they shouldn't be punished
for
making them because they're human beings
like we are what we should be doing is
encouraging them to be open about them
so we can learn from them but that is
not to say that someone should be given
any latitude at all if they
turn up to do
an operation drunk for example or
something like that that's you know that
would be gross negligence so i think
doctors don't know where the line is
between ordinary human error
and gross negligence
and they're very nervous that if they
own up
to a mistake they've made
they're going to get dragged through a
legal process where they'll be
convicted of gross negligence and
you're the expert on this not me sir
brian but
what i am advised by my
lawyer friends is that the law is often
applied inconsistently in different
parts of the country depending on which
coroner you have which police force you
have
and indeed the views of a judge and and
so it's very difficult for doctors to
know where they stand and
other industries that are cracklists
like the airline industry
pilots really do know where that line is
between ordinary human error that they
can feel completely comfortable being
open about you know forgetting to do
check number 25 of 52 checks before they
took off because they were distracted on
the radio
they know that that's something that is
a process problem a system problem
not
pilot error
in a way that would mean that they
should lose their licence
in this inquiry um you're looking at
something slightly different which was a
you know which is potentially
a catastrophic policy mistake
um by potentially by
uh a senior official working for the
government
and to me i think um
i'm not sure i feel qualified to
recommend the changes but i think
although
if that happened
i think that there are two separate
issues first of all
why if it happened would someone think
that it was acceptable
to make a decision in which
significant numbers of people were
poisoned
with absolutely catastrophic
consequences uh
there is a view sometimes in medicine
that you do something the greatest good
for the greatest number and there's
going to be consequences for
some unlucky souls along the way
personally i think that's completely
wrong and not consistent with
the values of the nhs but
that's that but i think the second
question is how could that have been
swept under the carpet for so many years
and you know
we have a 30-year rule and we have all
the sort of
protections on advice that's given for
ministers
um
and i
i just ask myself um
how
that kind of failure could happen in the
state i'm sorry i wish i did have a
clearer answer for you but that's well
if you tell me what you what you can and
i i thank you for that you mentioned
there the airline industry
which of course isn't just a question of
the pilots is the question of the those
who do the maintenance of the plane
those who check the plane over those who
license the plane to fly
um it's just
it is in effect a system
which
the airline industry has largely sorted
out
um
and you've talked about here the duty of
canada being systemic as it currently is
the
the problem is where they intersect uh
if you take a
uh the
the days when uh industrial injury
litigation began uh in effect the night
the 1800s
when the
the laundry girl working
in the laundry vat with a big revolving
machine paddle
who's worked for 12 hours and is
supposed to work for 12 hours and gets
tired
and puts a hand in and loses it
um
that's really the fault
of those who are operating the system as
opposed to
what is always said by the or well said
by the the bosses in those days
it's her fault for being careless which
in one sense it was
but in a true sense it was the system
so you have the doctor
who may work
under pressure
for too many hours with the lack of
support from nurses because they're not
there
no
mistake is made it's human
but what is truly responsible for it him
the nurses the
hospital administration or the system
that requires that to happen
in order to resolve it
the answer would have to be that
somebody has to say well
yes i was too tired
yes i did make a mistake that's the
starting point isn't it
exactly i couldn't agree with you more
and that is uh that is why i think we
are
running serious risks with patient
safety having very stretched staff at
the moment under enormous pressure i
think the chances of those kinds of
mistakes happening
are much greater because of the the
pressures that staff are under
um there's another difference with the
airline industry which i i think i only
really came to understand late in my
time as health secretary which is that
if you discover that the
you know the right wing nut on the
left-hand engine of this type of plane
um
needs to be uh
checked every time the plane takes off
or something like that
and if you just if you say if you don't
do this
there's a risk of that engine
failing
you just need to issue a simple
instruction like that and every airline
all around the world will immediately
make sure they check that wind nut every
time they take off and you don't need to
worry about implementation because the
airlines it's mission critical not to
have a crash
but if you um
have a mistake that's made for example
when a baby is being born
but in a certain situation you need to
use
you know this instrument or that
instrument whatever
it's not the case that just sending that
out as an instruction means that every
maternity department in the country will
immediately follow that
because they are already receiving
hundreds of instructions every single
day
on different issues
and they're also extremely busy
delivering babies
and so when it comes to healthcare
systems you have to spend a lot more
time working out how you're going to get
the bandwidth of the people who are
doing these things to change the system
because it won't happen automatically so
there's a
much more thought needs to be given to
implementation
the the the changes which uh you've made
in response to the various
inquiries that the new changes you
described
have you had a system of audit to check
what effect they've actually had
um
there are ways that we can check that
have you yes um and has it yes uh i
would i would say so but i'm a
politician and i'm proud of my record in
that respect but for example
um
following the francis inquiry we
introduced the ofsted system so we
didn't know which hospitals were good
and which hospitals weren't by the time
i left office
three million more patients were using
good or outstanding hospitals than when
i arrived it's now four million more
patients using good or outstanding
hospitals so i think there was
progress and i do think um the nhs is
much more transparent when i
listened to sajid javi giving his
response to the ochentan
report
and being completely honest about the
most terrible failings in nhs care in
shoes print alfred
i thought that that is a very big change
i was the first health secretary to
stand at the dispatch box
and talk in very graphic terms about nhs
failures and now here's someone two
health secretaries on using exactly the
same language so i think
there has been change i think the nhs is
is more compassionate but i wouldn't
want to pretend that there's not a long
way to go
um
same sort of area in one sense is
dealing with the the question of how we
we challenge
what has been received wisdom and may be
wrong
um one of the
problems which
has been discussed already uh in this
inquiry
uh has been the the problem that the
civil servants may not stay although
they stay in post for longer than junior
ministers
um something which you've already said
you find
uncomfortable as a way of having a
good
or better government
but but they do leave and they leave
perhaps more often than they used to so
there may be no
easy
access
to
the departmental memory
and when you make statements as
are made here
the best available treatment at the time
was given and you make that statement 30
or 40 years
after
the treatment has actually been given
um
you may be simply parroting what
somebody else has parroted the year
before the year before that and the year
before that
without actually having a proper basis
to
found it on
how do we
actually
retain
the ability to
call up
today quickly because decisions have to
be very quickly you're focusing on the
here and now it has been distressed to
me before
to make sure that actually you're
telling
the
of the past
what it was
um
you're asking me to answer in one
sentence the most difficult question
you've got to answer in your whole
inquiry i mean i think it's not
necessarily
in my experience
an issue about
turnover because
in reality sometimes it helps to have a
new pair of eyes
because then they're prepared to
challenge what their predecessor did
whereas if someone stays in a very long
time they will obviously
defend to the hilt decisions they took i
think it's more about
having a
robust challenge at the time that
decisions are taken
and i think that
the best example i can give
which we haven't
an example we haven't talked about today
is something to do with pandemic
preparations when i was health secretary
so we
were ranked
the second best prepared country in the
world for pandemics
the best prepared country i can see your
eyebrows arching there so brian that the
best prepared country was the united
states of america and that was johns
hopkins university in washington that
made that assessment and i was very
proud of that as health secretary at the
time and we did operation cygnus a huge
three-day exercise
um and we i even held an international
summit of ge7 health ministers to talk
about pandemic preparedness so we really
thought we were on the ball but the
truth was
um we there was group think that if
there was a pandemic
it would be a flu pandemic because
that's what we'd had before and we
hadn't given enough thought to the fact
that it might be a different type of
pandemic
so exercise cygnus which employed which
involved hundreds of civil servants and
me as the secretary of state at the time
you can look through the whole report
and testing is not mentioned once there
is no mention of testing at all that
turned out to be our biggest problem
when we actually had
that pandemic
and so i feel that
it's about there was a group think that
said if we have a pandemic in the future
it'll be similar to the pandemics we
have in the past and i think
that
what one needs to do is to put in place
people whose job it is to challenge
groupthink
at every stage and make sure that and
it's it's particularly challenging in
academia and in the civil service
because they're very consensual places
where people don't like to upset each
other everyone likes to try and find a
solution that everyone's happy with and
people don't like flies in the ointment
but actually you do need that you need
people who are going to challenge and
and it can't just be ministers i think
that's the problem our system at the
moment is built on the idea that
actually the ministers are the ones who
are going to come in and challenge the
group think the flies in the ointment
they're going to come in and say no no
it may be done like this before we're
going to do it like this now
and everyone's conditioned to obey
ministers but we're not experts and we
don't have that institutional memory
of those fields and so you need
contrary thinking civil servants who
challenge
perceived ways of doing things
a
slightly different topic um you
mentioned ebola
in the course of your your evidence now
ebola can be transmitted by blood could
it not
i wouldn't know but a hemorrhagic fever
yeah but um
how what to what you attribute our
relative
success as i
i think it probably is
in keeping
this country free of
ebola
well um
it took root in west africa
in three countries in west africa and
the world health organization
failed to get its act together because
they operate on a consensus basis and
it was very very slow
and what actually happened was that
the three of the biggest a donors in the
world um britain america and france just
took one country each weeded sierra
leone and then
america and france did liberia and
guinea
respectively
and we just got on with it and tackled
the problem at source
and so there was very very clear lines
of responsibility we used the army we
used the nhs we used our epidemiologists
but we were only doing sierra leone
and the french knew what they were doing
in the americans knew what they were
doing and so it was
it was successful for that reason i
think
so you you
prevented the transmission by really
dealing with that source the best you
could i see correct
um
i i think that's all that i i have to
ask thank you very much
mr hunt is there anything further that
you would like to add
no thank you very much
thank you well there is something i want
to add which is to to thank you
and to thank you for your obvious
candor
uh and your the reflective nature of
what you've had to say which has been
really enlightening and helpful so thank
you very much indeed thank you very much
thank you
and tomorrow sir um we return to
scotland uh with the evidence of malcolm
chisholm
tomorrow 10 o'clock
you